often when we lose somebody that we love
especially somebody who is hurting or
somebody who got in a car wreck or
somebody who was struggling with
addiction
our brain locks in on the hurt and pain
they were feeling
as though at the time of the wreck at
the time of the assault at the time of
addiction
using
and I want you to hear me say now
the atoms at peace you're not hurting
anymore
and for somebody who loved him for as
long as you did that was your that was
that was the dream right is that he
would stop hurting you let him stop
hurting and be with you yes
correct but it's easy to remember how
much he was hurting and to get locked in
there
Bros at peace now atoms at peace